so leute ich begrüße euch ganz herzlich
zur auflösung der challenge von gestern
wie ihr hier seht dann den lauf mama von
meinem bildschirm ich habe das mit papst
besseren geborgen sind wir hier unter
dem video
jetzt kommt die auflösung ich weil ich
die kommentare scrollen euch jeden
kommentar zeigen wir schauen ob ich
erwähnen geantwortet habe
beziehungsweise ob ich jetzt in diesem
video noch auf jeden antworten kann das
hätte auch ich habe heute verschlafen
deswegen kommt dieses video tschuldigung
ich ein bisschen krank ein bisschen
später
und ja wir leben ja es gibt aber soweit
ich hab mich sogar selbst kommentiert
krank er kommentiert hunter place lamy
apps missbrauchsserie placement wer es
schafft man die kommentare ja alles
kommentiert alles kommentiert alles
kommentiert so kommen zu diesem einen
punkt hier nahe uns so weiter es gibt
mehrere leute die unter dem video
kommentiert haben die aber keinen
google+ account besitzen
deswegen kann ich die nicht kommentieren
also ich kann da keinen text
unterschreiben ihr seht ihr es keine
antworten button da so wie hier oben zum
beispiel da bei kanada wo ist einfach
nicht da das heißt die kann ich jetzt
nicht mit text kommentierten die werde
ich in diesem video kommentieren machst
du mal mit max die geschwister sharon ja
gerne leute schreibt meine kommentare
wenn ihr es der block i can't und hat
rein was sie von den inhalten wie finde
ich richtig geil
bis meine stimme ist auch ganz anders
richtig seltsam hier anna fischer was
isst am liebsten außer toastbrot
jakobsmuscheln
ja es gibt eigentlich auch gibt viele
leute die einfach hier mit einem
buchstaben kommentiert hat und dann
erzählt natürlichen geschichte von
klassen treffen ganz oder setzen sich
ein cluster rhein wissen von teddy
kommentar antworten ja ok mit antworte
ich fresse haut die stars die stars die
stars ach ja leute wenn ich hoffe jeden
kommentar dazu beantworten dann wisst
ihr ja von game standen dass der deniz a
k s die challenge machen musst du nicht
ich als er sich dann einen ganzen stack
toastbrot also ist der 64 scheiben
toastbrot mit einem halben glas milch
reifen und das auf video aufnehmen sagt
sie aber ich weiß nicht aber wirklich
realisiert hat dass wir von trockenem
tost währenddessen nicht getestet der
ist kaum zu kauen der dirt dem mund so
aus und er musste von ich eine scheibe
essen sondern 20 oder 15 eben eine ganze
packung und hat nur ein halbes glas
milch
das wird lustig denkst du dass du es
schaffst ja ich bin der beste wahl für
jeden kommentar klar kopieren was jetzt
von drogen megageil alter nicht viel
doch tisch habe ich guck mal hier gucken
sie dreimal die tour ab ich hab's
geschafft hat hat man noch dass youtube
das youtube irgendwie spinnt oder so wie
habt ihr gesehen antwort abgeschickt
alles klar
wo wohnst du deutschland deutschland von
ganze herr ganz land und auch in sontra
drauf und hey viele einfachheit
geschrieben der buchstabe ok bester
manier funky shooter grüßen dich du hast
mir in den schwierigsten phasen meines
lebens die kraft gegeben durchzuhalten
und weiter nach vorne zu schauen und
nicht aufzugeben
ich danke dir
das ruder ist auch so einer
hunderttausende sind viele 980 millionen
könnte sein
ich habe meine kommentare wie lang mit
lass das lieber das ist lieber geht aber
weiter hier noch so alle high dieser
kommentar dient nur dazu dass du dir ist
ja ich werde dieses aber nicht verlieren
wir keine methode gefunden habe youtube
konnten kommentare zu kommentieren
hier live stream von veli um das könnt
ihr mir es war wirklich meine kommentare
schreiben
schreib mal was wär i um in seinem live
stream gesagt hat hat er gesagt ihr seid
mein video kommentieren oder so lasst
mich das mal wissen also reitman
kommentare schreiben damit nicht das
verstehe ich konnte mir das erklären
dann bin ich nicht mehr alles in troja
beste schaut auch anfällig wie auch ein
sehr fleißiger zuschauer und natürlich
an huckle hacks wahrscheinlich mein
fleißigster zwischenmahlzeiten ich liebe
dich hatte und weiter penis hu hu hu
wozu deutschland welche start
dies hatte die agentur meta hat jetzt in
der aufnahme geschrieben was verbessern
welche stadt wohne ich dann
ich wohne in monaco
alle die jetzt behaupten dass man keine
stadt in deutschland ist ja hier den
space kamran genau deshalb wurde ich
auch schon mehrmals angesprochen
es ist so dass ich diesen fest im rahmen
den ich aktuell verwende einfach geil
findet in benutzt den er auch aber ich
benutze ich bei den benutzern weil ich
hab einfach im freistaat kleist und ist
nicht so dass da was geklaut hätte das
ist ein open source download free
download gibt's überall
und den hat er genau die gleichen rechte
daran wie ich ich habe auch nicht vor
den dauerhaft zu benutzen man design
macht mir gerade einen eigenen anderen
farben und bis dieser aber muss man
eigene fertig ist weil ich einfach dem
verwenden und ja ich hoffe dass ihr mich
nicht tötet
das ja das wandern ist des müllers lust
land besser kommentar den ich jemals
geschrieben habe
hui hui yz ja einfach die einfach in
alphabetischer reihenfolge weiter
kommentiert so und hier ist natürlich
das was anderes penis
zusammengeschrieben
ja das ist auch irgendwann sagte der
held kommentar kam zwei mal hier ich
habe man ihr kino zockt livestream von
ferien und hier oben kiel zurück lässt
ihn von wiederum vor 16 stunden zweimal
sogar dreimal
ich habe mal hier dreimal einfach vor 16
stunden was ist das für youtube park da
kann ich doch nichts für na gut dann
time erzieher den letzten kommentar und
wie lautet der livestream von berio der
sportlerwahl
aber nur wenn du dich schnauze
stadtportal alles klar ob immer gucken
absenders evelyn ab perfekt also leute
dann ich werde dennis channel in die
beschreibung packen
er könnte jetzt gleich mal vorbei
schauen wir dieses video gesehen habt
und immer erzählen was auf ihn zukommt
weil dies vergessen haben es kommt auf
ihn zu eine ganze packung trockenen
ungetestet und toast zu essen
das auf video aufzunehmen ohne katz also
das technisch nicht trinken davon nicht
karten und er hat dazu ein halbes glas
milch um seine kehle ein bisschen zu
schmieren mit dem sich nichts helfen
weil trockener ist ungefähr so saugfähig
ist wie ein schwamm
ja aber damit muss jetzt klar komme also
geht auf seine channel system zwei
scheine sich beide in der beschreibung
geht drauf last ihm einen kommentar
und ja lasst ihn wissen was auf ihn
zukommt in diesem sinne leute ich freue
mich dass ich diese challenge bestanden
habe das erste mal die challenge nicht
verloren
wünsche euch einen schönen tag und
macht's gut